hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the floor is breathing
and as you can see
oh the floor is breathing let's see if
rising under the dv there well that's
concerning but let's find out why
because this game says it's going to be
some kind of analog horror
[Music]
liminal space thing which i think is
just a bunch of keywords to uh appeal to
a wider audience and so you understand
what we found
oh
hi four mutilated corpses
inside of your home
your home my home are you talking to me
i like the feel of
their
breath
through
the
floorboards
well isn't that lovely me i i do
who me
through
january 17th 2007.
7 36 p.m welcome home oh thank you
well that's nice
i don't usually get a welcome home
that's awfully sweet of you
oh pressy to check tasks
well this is nice to do list check for
monsters under the bed great use my
hammer to fix a window awesome watch tv
cool go to sleep have a lovely day
that's so nice
i'm going to include that in my to-do
list well
the oh
great
um
oh good i'm glad my house is on the
precipice of the abyss into nothingness
always comforting
hello
hi
are we
oh it's dark
so something in the darkness great
divorce rates at highest
lose yourself in the dream reality is
cold you and me both know that hiding
yours in yourself is the only way to
sustain your sick fantasies you can't
hide the drugs and and drink can never
flush out your guilt it is all your
fault everything
the that happens to you in
is deserved you are
vib vile the loss of a single life
possibly more in simple ammunition in
your war for freedom and nah and
pleasure
broadcast it
let the world enjoy euphoria with you
this weirdly pertinent newspaper that i
just so happen to get today what's in
the darkness
something fun monsters oh
just darkness okay oh
hello
wow oh
oh
hi grandma
you're looking swell
i'm gonna go now okay um check for
monsters under the bed where is my bed
upstairs great hi go upstairs
okay
i am going upstairs hi grandma hi
grandma
how are you doing can i have this
nope okay
hi grandma
hello
any monsters under my bed
nope use the hammer to fix the window
okey-dokey then
that's great
this is great
bye grandma
okay
so the window staring out into the
precipice of the abyss bored
ah i was wondering how a hammer was
going to be used to fix a window
hey ho
hi
um
can i help you how are you oh
who's there
hello
all right
well uh time to watch tv i suppose
i've done it i watched the tube
oh hi oh
good
oh great
it's my favorite show
well
that was fun
time to go to sleep good night grandma
uh i don't need to turn that off i like
wasting power
yeah time to hit the old
dusty trail
and then i gotta remember to have a nice
day a lovely day
because i go to sleep then
i guess i'm going to sleep
well oh hi um oh i remember you
[Music]
hi
i remember you
oh goodbye
[Music]
okay good this is going well is that my
lovely day
because i sure was lovely whatever that
was january 18th
next day i think 8 21 p.m
welcome home
it's good to be here really happy to be
home in this place that i love
can't wait to
check for monsters under my bed
to-do list check if the windows are safe
check for monsters under my bed watch tv
go to sleep have a lovely day well
[Laughter]
huh something messed with my window
oh we can't have that that's definitely
gonna
lead to my doom
anybody there
okay
hopefully dokley anything new in here
all right new newspaper no divorce rates
at the highest
never flush out my guilt okay
well
it's a daily grind but you got to get it
you know never stop hustling
always
always moving forward
you know yadda yadda any monsters under
there oh nope don't need to confirm that
hey i guess it didn't need to it didn't
say check if there were no monsters
under my bed because uh
i see some eyeballs
i don't know
i uh
yep there are monsters under my bed
check okay good everything is as it
should be time for some tv
all right it's dark down there
i don't remember it being this dark
okay
all right
and cue the tv
okay
oh
hi oh my god was that the floor
hi
no
ah here's the thing no oh
okay all right uh
this is fine i'm guessing
i gotta go around those
oh god january 23rd subject has various
gross lesions across chest and face
emerge bilaterally in the conjunction
the subject has rope burns around the
neck and wrist the subject has suffered
loss of three fingers subject was found
hidden under the floorboards with three
other individuals have a lovely day
is that laughing or is that crying
oh god i'm guessing i shouldn't touch
the
nooses
hi
who is um
somebody um
okay
good thing i boarded up that window um
why are you red why are you red
oh good grandma
i don't remember having these
decorations here
okay
hi how are you good to see you
monster
behold the lord came with many thousands
of his holy ones to execute judgment
upon all and to convict all the ungodly
of all their ungodly deeds which they
have done in an ungodly way and of all
the harsh things which ungodly sinners
have spoken against him
cool
great
oh
freak
hello
to do this oh
hey you're still there um
i don't know if i should go to sleep you
know just a funny feeling
that maybe going to sleep isn't the best
idea
at the
oh it's dark
oh it's dork um
i'm gonna go i'm a big brave boy i just
want to watch some television have a
lovely day
i'm in the room i'm in the room and
nothing weird is happening i'm in the
room and i'm leaving the room
big brave boy man he's leaving the room
well that was great
good thing i watched him talk
okay
darkness don't scare me
i ain't afraid no dark ain't afraid of
no monster under my bed
good night
[Music]
yep
everything's perfectly normal
as it should be in my opinion
[Music]
hello
good to see you
who are you
i'd like to know who you are so i can
properly introduce myself my name is
markiplier
youtuber uh
director actor entrepreneur
welcome home
oh squeaky
to-do list
hi
what is that
is the floor breathing
repair the door check for monsters under
the bed watch tv go to sleep great
love a routine what happened to my door
why is my door like this who did this to
my door
who did this to my door
why is the floor breathing
probably fine
dunzo
hi who's in there
grandma
okay he's fine
hi that's fine
ah i'm uh
i'm comfortable hi grandma i'm uh
[Music]
what is
what is it
what is this what is it
who's bowling
is that breathing
and you're still there oh you're not oh
that's weird okay you're not there
anymore um
well that's uh
done with that so
i'll just go now
downstairs watch some tv
have a good old time
doing stuff
okay
hi
all right
my favorite show again
or
uh
can you can you stop rising ominously
actually i don't like the falling on
asleep either all right
am i done okay
tv watched
can confirm all right well that was easy
enough
i'm sure nothing weird is about to
happen
oh
god
do i even have a phone do i own a phone
i don't even have a
bathroom tell me how i can afford the
luxury of a phone
oh boy good yeah that's not
an ominous
yep
hello markiplier speaking probably not a
murderer
love the screaming
love the ethereal demonic screaming
hey
oh hey eyes oh dear samantha i'm writing
to inform you that you're welcome to our
new year's party i know you've been very
isolated recently but i think you'll
make fast friends with the others also
pass on my best wishes to your husband i
haven't seen him for a few weeks i hope
he's doing well wishing you the best
have a lovely day hi eyes oh
boy
hi eyes hi hi guys you keep uh keep up
uh the good uh good work uh keep the
good work up keep it up that good work
you keep it i'm gonna go now goodbye
bye eyes goodbye guys
yay um
oh hey you're gonna watch me sleep
oh wait a minute
oh oh wait a minute uh
i didn't see that on my to-do list um
okey-dokey then this must be part of the
have a lovely day
oh what am i looking at down there hi
guys
oh yeah
can i go back upstairs
i forgot something i forgot everything
okay
all right uh convenient hole under the
floor but i can barely hear
if you guys can tone down the demonic
chanting and whatnot
all right i'll just
good
i'm done now
tomorrow is another day
another lovely day if you ask me i don't
know about you guys but i'm pretty tired
so i'm gonna hit the old hay
oh hey
hi
how are you i don't think i want to go
to bed
oh
boy i don't know
god no
no
all right i'm coming for you
ah
grandma did you see anything
all right um
any monsters under my bed
no
[Music]
i guess it's sleepy by time
[Music]
oh my god
i was sleeping
excuse you
i was in the middle of a lovely dream
i think
ah good great good can i have that can i
take that with me is there any monsters
under my bed
hide
i don't like that suggestion i i don't
like that
i don't like that suggestion
oh
hi
hello you are no longer safe here are
you sure about that i don't know why you
would suggest such a thing
all right i can't go downstairs
well i'm gonna go now see you around oh
hi hello you're uh
oh then elisha prayed and said
oh lord please open his eyes that he may
see
so the lord opened the eyes of the young
man
and he saw
and behold
behold be held i would like to be held
right now i
that door wasn't there before you know i
know a thing or two about doors
a door wasn't there before okay i'm
gonna go now open my eyes
okay
what am i gonna go
ah oh oh no um oh hi hello
oh god
have i always seen through a tv
[Music]
what is the deal with you
am i underwater
why am i underwater
where am i going
i don't know what i'm doing
i am no go no more
okay
well if i'm gonna be under an ocean
apparently at least it's not a blood
ocean now that is preferred still don't
like it
this is a surreal look
this is weird
i mean if it wasn't obvious you probably
noticed that it's kind of weird but it
is
oh weird hi oh i can't see you
hello
hello mysterious house
oh nope never mind
i'm not going to go to the house okay
i get it i know when i'm not wanted
oh what is that
oh it's a playset oh it's eyes
i should have known hi guys hey how you
doing
you good you good
you good
[Music]
great okay hi hello nice playset triple
decker that's great that's great guys
that's great what is this read open your
eyes i'm fairly sure they are
but uh maybe not i didn't check my note
to my dearest samantha how was your
husband though i suppose you wouldn't
know but i know i saw what you've done
and i saw how you murdered your son too
you make my blood curl posting your vile
actions online creating a circus out of
the death of your own flesh and blood
proof i have all of it recorded saved
and so do the police you will not escape
your crime nor your judgment enjoy
eternal suffering you sick twisted [ __ ]
well
thank you oh hi hello
great can i leave i wait what's this
thing finish what we started
and what was that
why don't you remind me what we started
oh cool
oh thanks for the hammer guys
oh i can't oh no i can't leave
okay
oh
okay
this is a great camera shake
all right uh
sure
oh
oh my god
he was so sad
[Music]
well you know if i'm going to commit to
something like destroying i better go
wholehearted
great
104 p.m that is a different time
recording start what am i recording
i'm recording this video but what am i
recording
oh
was that me was that me or the game is
that me or the game
can i run away
i would really like the option to run
away
nope can't run away okay
well this is lovely
i can only imagine how this is gonna go
horribly horribly wrong
not enough daytime horror if you ask me
but
alas
whoever oh
warrant to enter and search premises
court code 563154
court office address newcastle quayside
law courts blah blah blah elizabeth ii
blah blah blah hey mark i don't know how
i feel about this when she should just
be a witness but something about her in
this case makes me uncomfortable
although she's lost her son and her
husband so go easy on her i still insist
you don't go alone but i'm sure you'll
still ignore me anyway be careful just
ask the question and check the house and
get back see you soon
oh
ah
i see
i see what's going on here
i get it
i get it hello i don't see a doorbell
but okay
ding dong
ding dong
dang dong
ding dong
ding dong
well
i don't know if that's the only option
there we go
oh good oh good
i'm back baby
baby i'm back ah
i broke the door
not me i i not who i was before but now
i who i am now
hi this should be more concerning that
should be more concerning all of this is
incredibly concerning
that is unfathomably concerning great
ah good
good good oh hey oh oh my god hi
oh no i'd rather not
no
my eyes have never been more open
oh hi hello
oh
great
this is good
love the lighting setup love the cameras
really
what
hi
um
did you hit me
oh good i just wanted to confirm you
don't have to do it again was just
curious okay
thank you
oh no i'm dead
ah
shouldn't have gone in that house alone
january 20th 2007
9 57 pm
you can't run forever
you're probably right
oh no hey
they can't take
they can't take us alive have a lovely
day
hi
listen
this is about the breathing
um
okay well uh
oh boy um
sorry
i don't know who i am anymore i don't
know what i'm i i don't know i don't
know what i'm doing why i'm doing
grandma help
ah
oh oh that's not my bed
okay
hello
hi
[Music]
ah good yeah okay
[Applause]
[Music]
welp
there you have it i guess i think
those look like dolly mini at like
craft things god ai is so good for
making nightmare fuel
look at the oh my god i can't
see the one on the middle right
something over here four murders and you
couldn't even kill yourself
that's weird
you're crowded by
physical and digital evidence
the blood on my hands
will
stain
your
conscious
into
the
fire
and
that's it
[Music]
there you go
that was weird but cool the flow was
really good and i felt like there were
some surprises here and there with it it
was just like deeply unsettling the
whole time i didn't know what i was
doing there was like the floor breathing
and like the wandering around and the
weird things popping up everywhere i
really like that i thought that was
great just like it was like when i
played from the darkness right it didn't
have all the polish of like a triple a
horror game or anything like that but
there was something about the way just
moving around the environment was
unsettling in a way that i've played a
lot of just moving around the
environment horror games but this one
kind of like it was weird i was able to
just like play with it have fun but
every time i turned around something
surprised me it was really cool giving
you kind of the sense of a confines of
like a box that you can play around in
and it's all the same and then shifting
it around every time giving you a sense
of normalcy so it can take you out of
the normalcy you know what i mean and
then this underlying feeling of there
being something horribly wrong the
entire time
dolly i called it and this person does
not exist.com that was actually an early
one where it just made faces of
photorealistic people that weren't real
so uh thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you enjoyed this organ
hope this person makes more
this is pretty good good vibes i mean
bad vibes but good bad vibes all around
but thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want more horror games
links are in the description big
playlists lots of them you'll never get
bored i challenge you to watch all of
them if you already have more scare
games on the way thank you and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]